hi I'm Erik Bosse and at Comic Con we
saw a lot of trailers about stuff we
love including HBO's Westworld season 2
and as far as plot revelations go I'd
say this was more of a teaser like just
hinting at how the world has changed and
what the characters goals are but not
really confirming a whole lot but there
are some interesting details in this
trailer that you might have missed so
let's dig deep into this imagery and
discuss where season 2 might be going
and spoilers head in case anything I say
ends up being right ok let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
so we open on the player piano in the
mariposa saloon and Sweetwater I
remember in season one that player piano
opens several of the episodes it
actually came to symbolize the
artificiality of the hosts it's an
instrument created by humans to evoke
something human like in this case music
and it's capable of operating
independently just like the hosts but
these repeated close-ups of the paper
roll and the levers and the gears this
shows us that while it's very human-like
it ultimately is no more than a machine
it's an illusion of humanity like the
hosts it just resets every day like
clockwork but within this sophisticated
machine imagery there are two symbols of
chaos one the fire reflected in the
glass this saloon just like all of West
world is on fire and the tightly-wound
clock of this world is now completely
out of control then of course the blood
stain on the paper roll and the keys
like the other machines of West world
this one is now stained with the blood
of its victims like always see that it's
even bled through the top layer of the
paper staining the layer below just like
how the chaos of the top surface layer
of West world has bled down into the
lower layers of the Delos command center
in labs then we get this shot of Bernard
or spoiler for season one which is why
would you watch this video if you
haven't seen season one or an old but
yes probably Bernard now why do I think
this check out that fly that lands on
his collar and he's completely
undisturbed by it remember in the past
on the show flies have been used to
indicate a host specifically one that's
malfunctioning let's move on I want
early survived
won't give up this dream of
smell live
okay so in this section we hear the
words of the music of this trailer I
gotta be me by Sammy Davis jr. and the
lyrics aren't exactly subtle the song
expresses the desire to break free of
the expectations at restrain us and live
a life of independent free will which is
yeah exactly what Dolores is going
through and it seems like several other
hosts but compared to all the music we
heard last season like most of them had
titles with the word black in it this
song has a new uplifting tone and
actually looking at these exact words in
deeper detail each lyric corresponds to
whatever character were scenes in her
monologue in this case for Bernard I was
early summer
mere survival isn't enough of a
motivation for him remember he's a host
whenever he dies he can just be
reanimated instead he wants to live a
life of meaning actually I like how the
word live hits us right as we see the
opposite death with this dead Tiger I
wanna live and when you see this Tiger
you may be saying to yourself well that
doesn't look like anything to me but it
should because you're not a host you're
a human I assume I don't I don't know
you there is meaning in this image
specifically for Bernard he's looking at
this Tiger almost as if he envies it for
its ability to actually die so what is
the life of meaning for Bernard well in
this case the ability to die gives life
meaning now I'm assuming that this isn't
a real tiger in the show but a host
animal and some of you are saying that
because Tigers aren't native to the
American West that this tiger might be a
clue that we'll see more of samurai
world in season 2 remember we saw a bits
of samurai world at the end of season 1
and we know from the coordinates that
may receive that there is more than one
part not on the other hand the samurai
tradition is Japanese and Tigers aren't
technically native to Japan but then
stepping away from it the way west world
reflects the stereotypical fantasy of
the American West not what it truly was
I could see this tiger being a creation
of a part of the park that's set in Asia
like either samurai world or maybe
another one we also get this great shot
of a guy swinging by his feet grasping
for a gun of course this is warrant
remember this is where the man in black
aka old William left him in season 1
having drained his blood to bring Teddy
back now it seems like new travelers
have stumbled upon him may be leaving
this gun just out of reach and I like
how he won't give up this dream of life
that keeps him alive now I will say this
tree doesn't look exactly the same as
the tree that we saw in season 1 so
maybe production is using a new location
or this is a new narrative loop in
Laurens just says the rotten luck of
repeatedly getting hung upside down but
this does bring up a question do the
hosts need their artificial blood now
Teddy did seem to be tired out after
losing his blood from his injuries thus
why he needed Lawrence's blood but now
it seems like Lawrence has enough life
force at least to swing back and forth
and reach for this gun so it's not
totally clear if host blood is like fuel
for them or if it's just for the
aesthetic visual for wedding hosts shoot
them anyway let me know what you think
but let's move on god
baby
[Music]
can I be
[Music]
okay so here we're in the lower levels
beneath the park and yeah there are
corpses everywhere some of them might be
human some might be hosts like this one
guy's face is completely bashed in and
you'd think it would have been more of a
bloody mess at least going off of DeMuth
run standards so hopefully he was just a
host then we see Maeve standing with a
freaked out Sizemore and notice how she
has this assault rifle so I'm guessing
he's probably being held hostage murmur
Maeve chose to get off the train and
return to the park to find her daughter
and Sizemore as the head writer of those
narratives would be maids best chance at
finding where that character has been
reassigned in fact look at where they're
standing here that's at the base of that
big map of West world so she's probably
demanding Sizemore to literally point
out where on the map her daughter is and
notice the part of the song that plays
here
[Music]
now I would say that in season 1 May
changed more than any other character
that we saw but when she was given the
opportunity to complete her evolution
she chose to turn inward and embrace
part of her character that she already
was a mother let's move on I'll go it
alone
[Music]
right for somebody else
[Music]
okay this is awesome Dolores is chasing
these people down now at first I wasn't
sure if these were guests or hosts but
check out their clothes those look like
the formal wear that the dela
shareholders were wearing at that gala
at the end of last season and they
looked a turd suggesting they've been on
the run from these murderous hosts for
at least a couple days and the first
part of the lyrics say I'll go it alone
but Dolores isn't technically alone
there is someone joining her in the
shootout if you look closely that's
Teddy it is hard to see his face though
it's covered in shadow suggesting that
Dolores is now more of a solo act the
lyrics continued to say
[Music]
the lorises former narrative was to be
this hopeful farm girl in doomed lover
to teddy but now the murderous Wyatt
narrative has completely taken over and
she only wants to be right for herself
true to that narrative rather than just
being one half of this romantic
storyline and I'm loving Evan Rachel
Wood 'he's bloodthirsty badass grimace
as she aims his gun it's actually
parallel to the final shot of season 1
and yeah I think we're seeing Dolores
becoming the true villain of Westworld
now if you saw the west-world movie from
the 70s season 2 is looking a lot like
what that movie was it wasn't really
what the park was like when it was still
in operation it was more about what
happens when things started to fall
apart
kind of like Jurassic Park and when
we're comparing things to the movie
Dolores is now the closest thing that
the show has to the gunslinger character
but a question I have here is why is
Teddy joining her he never seemed like a
bad guy now my best guess is that his
programming has always been purely
devotion to Dolores and remember the key
memory that haunts him was that massacre
in Escalante with Wyatt who we now know
was Dolores
so really Teddy has no other path than
to follow in Dolores his shadow and not
to make this too much about sex but yeah
a lot of people are pointing out that
the way Evan Rachel Wood is riding this
horse it is a little sexy some made
inappropriate animated gifs out of it
but to be fair last season maid showed
us that in West world when a host makes
conscious decisions it's kind of a
sexual experience for them and looking
closely at the shot Wood bites her lower
lip here making me think that this could
be intentional either way it's clear
that she is really really enjoying this
new sense of empowerment we should move
on before I say something I'll regret
[Music]
[Music]
okay here we are returning to the
Mariposa notice the player piano in the
background actually think that this slow
pushing in is part of the same shot that
we saw the beginning of the trailer we
know that this set is currently on fire
the flames are reflecting off the
gambling table so the fire that we saw
on that opening shot is behind where
we're standing and look at these guests
they were killed off mid poker game this
guy still has cards in his hands while
the other guy is still clutching money I
think this one shot is the summation of
the stated theme on the show the quote
from Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet
these violent delights have violent ends
the debauchery of these men have led
them to very violent ends okay then we
cut to this very interesting shot of
these dune buggy's so my guess is that
now that the tunnels and transportation
beneath the park has been compromised
these dune buggies could be the backup
vehicles that the park security uses to
get around kind of like the way that the
jeeps were used in Jurassic Park
now another interpretation of this is
that this could just be a flashback to
before the park went to hell we actually
know that Jimmy Simpson is reprising his
role as young William but just mean that
season 2 will continue those flashbacks
to before the present day but when you
look inside the dune buggie here there
are some big reveals specifically two
characters whose fates we weren't
totally sure about at the end of last
season in the front seat there Stubbs
the head of security whom we last saw
scuffling with some Native American
hosts and then look in the back seat
sitting next to Bernard I'm pretty sure
that's Elsie now at first we had thought
that Bernard killed her but we never
actually saw her die on screen and after
season 1 was over there was an easter
egg on the west world promotional
website that showed Elsie's current
location on the west world map along
with an audio clip of her voice on a
radio transmission so assuming that this
is in the present day it looks like
Bernard is siding with the humans of the
park trying to help them contain the
chaos and yeah we should point out that
it's got to be pretty awkward for Elsie
and Bernard to sit next to each other
like I imagine she's just like swatting
at his hand as he's trying to reach over
and choke her quit it I'm sorry but
boards reveries or making me do this and
that brings us to the final shots of
this trailer ed Harris's old William
putting on the black hat which of course
is a nod to the key moment in season 1
when William put the hat on revealing to
us all that the two characters are the
same cold-hearted killer and of course
this happens right as Sammy Davis jr.
belts
[Music]
and I like the way that this is kind of
parallel to the opening shot of the
trailer there's this sophistication of
his fancy tuxedo notice the cufflinks
streaked with blood and yeah we should
acknowledge the fact that William is
wearing the same clothes that he was
wearing at that gala massacre suggesting
he just came from there and now he's
retrieving his iconic hat like Indiana
Jones I'm gonna predict that all these
shots that we see are actually from the
first episode of season two like it's
still super early in production for
Westworld it can't be that far into the
season at this point and it's hard to
tell from the background of these shots
but I think this might be the Mariposa
so maybe the carnage that we saw in the
Mary poster earlier was actually caused
by William but I gotta get props to Ed
Harris's subtle facial expressions here
he's got this thousand-yard stare as
he's reflecting on the man he's become
but then it transitions into the
faintest of smiles this echoes that look
of joy on his face in that final shot of
season one this is the west-world he
always wanted a truly violent place
where the stakes are finally real so I
want to wrap up with a few quick
predictions for season two one I think
the show is gonna feel a lot more like
Michael Crichton's original film and
another Michael Crichton story Jurassic
Park it's a total [ __ ] with
humans scrambling to survive in this
house of horrors while these macho park
operators failed to maintain control
over it to Dolores is going to emerge as
the true villain of the show we're gonna
see or do some horrible [ __ ] 3 I think
the world will expand into other parts
of the park maybe samurai world maybe
others remember in the original movie
West world was just one part of the part
along with medieval world and Roman
world and sequel films had future world
and spa world anyway I think we may get
implications of an infinite number of
parks but I wouldn't be surprised if the
show never fully leaves into the outside
world like I could imagine Jonathan
Nolan and Lisa joy leading mad part of
the mystery actually while we're on the
subject of mysteries I think Nolan and
joy are going to continue to deepen the
mystery of this show like the West world
that they created isn't just a show with
a bloodbath it's a show about the
mystery of what humanity means to these
characters and I am calling it now I
think Anthony Hopkins Robert Ford is
gonna reappear in some form like maybe
just a voice or maybe the real Ford and
the one that we saw die was a host let
me know your predictions for a season 2
in the comments below or you can tweet
them at me a ta vas or a new Rox
at new rock stars in actually if you
haven't already go check out the other
videos I did in West world like if you
have any lingering confusions about
season one I cleared up a lot of those
questions in those videos and you can
help us make more videos by contributing
to us on patreon big thanks to all of
our donors especially Kenny Smith thank
you for watching and self freeze all
motor functions